-Last time you were here --
Since the last time
you were here,
you were a newlywed.
You were having your first baby.
Now you're a dad of three girls.
-I am.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on, bud.
-Yeah, I know.
Well, First of all, Jimmy,
thanks for taking
six years to invite me back.
I appreciate that, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No problem, buddy. No problem.
-Three girls -- 5, 4, and 1.
-Oh, my God.
What is typical day like?
-Yeah, "Whoo." Pray for me.
-It's just packed, jam-packed.
-You know what?
It's -- I don't want to say --
Let me be careful here.
Controlled chaos is
the best way to put it.
-It's just
always something happening.
-It's, you know,
school pickups, drop-offs.
It's -- They do my nails,
my toenails, makeup, lipstick.
And, you know,
it's the greatest thing
I've ever experienced, though.
I mean, my girls are --
They are the absolute best.
And, you know, it's --
At least I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Don't clap yet, because I heard
around 13 years of age
is when they don't
like you very much.
-No, yeah -- No, that's a rumor.
That's a rumor.
-I'm preparing for that.
-Come on.
They're going to love you.
Come on. You're a great dad.
Aren't you psyched
that you don't have long hair?
They would probably be
braiding it all day.
-Yeah, they tried
when they were younger, yes,
but this --
you know, it's by choice.
-Yeah, of course it is. Yeah.
Of course it is.
-I used to have flowing locks,
like you, not too long ago.
-Are they into baseball or
softball or anything
or too little?
-I think they're
a little too young.
You know, they don't really
know much about my career.
They came to Yankee Stadium for
the first time a few months ago,
were on the field.
So they understand
that I played for the Yankees.
But, you know, I think sports
for kids is unbelievable.
Teach you a lot of life lessons.
-Of course.
-You know,
teaches you shared goals,
you know, teamwork,
work ethic, dedication.
And my wife used to play tennis,
so we put our oldest
in tennis lessons
when she was about 4 years old.
So she's taking
the tennis lessons.
And, look, I was so proud
because she actually got to be
pretty good for the 15 minutes
that she would focus,
and then it's going
and drawing in the clay.
You know, so, in my head,
I'm not one of those parents
that scream at anyone,
but I'm like, you know,
"Listen, focus.
You know,
you're embarrassing us."
So, one day,
we're taking her to practice,
and I say, "You know, Bella,
are you ready to go to
tennis practice?"
She said, "I don't want to go."
I was like,
"Alright, that's fine."
I said, "We'll find
something else for you to do.
But do you mind sharing why you
don't want to go to
tennis practice?"
She said, "Dad,
I already know how to play."
So she is not
lacking in confidence
when it comes to sports.
-I love that.
She's got the confidence
right there.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, I love it.
We had Aaron Judge
here recently on the show,
and he is now named
the new captain --
Yankee captain
since your retirement.
And he said
he got to talk to you
and you were very nice to him
and very funny with him.
Do you remember when you got
the call to be captain?
-I do.
I thought I was in trouble.
You know, this is back in 2003.
There was this false narrative
going around town
that I was
this big party animal,
and in -- I hear one "whoo!"
-Yeah.
-So, I was injured
at the beginning of the season,
and, you know, me and the boss,
Mr. Steinbrenner,
got into it a little bit over
this so-called "party animal"
that I was being portrayed as.
So I was hurt.
I missed the first
couple months of the season.
I get back to New York.
I take all my teammates --
I have them over for dinner.
We all go out to a club.
Now, granted,
we have the next day off.
Next day in the paper,
headlines --
"It's 3:00, 4:00 a.m.,
and Derek's
out on the town again."
I get a call
from our PR director.
He says, "The boss
wants to talk to you."
And he named me captain.
I think he was literally like,
"This guy just doesn't care
what I say,
so we might as well
just name him captain."
-You thought you were
in trouble?
-I thought I was
in trouble, yes.
-I went out with you to a club
a couple times.
-Thanks for ruining
the false narrative
that I just tried saying.
-No, you would never --
-We went one time, one time.
That was church. What'd we do?
-We went to -- We went out --
I remember this
because I was at "SNL."
I was on "Saturday Night Live."
And that's when I first met you.
And we went out to a club.
I'd never really been to a club.
-Oh, here we go.
Jimmy's never been --
Yeah, okay.
We'll let him go.
This is another
"True Confession" right here.
-No. We were at this table.
And I had never sat at a table.
They had table --
bottle service or whatever.
And I go -- I didn't know
what any of this was, right?
So, I'm sitting there.
I was there for like 20 minutes.
We were out before that,
I think, even.
And I go -- And then
you went to the bathroom,
and your friends were all there
and everybody.
You had like 10 people with you.
And I go, "I'm going to split."
I was going to
Irish goodbye, you know,
and I'll text you later.
I go, "I'll call you later."
So, I go,
"I'll take care of this bill,"
and everyone went like, "No!"
It was like slow motion.
Like, "You make
'Saturday Night Live' money,
not Yankee money."
I was like, "Let me give you
my credit card."
And then I get the bill.
And I was there
20 minutes with you?
And the bill was like $2,000.
And I almost started crying
because it was like
a month's rent for me.
I'm like, "Did we break
one of the tables?
What the heck happened?"
And then I got to tip
on top of that.
And I was just like --
I don't think
I ever went out with you
ever again.
-Yeah, I don't recall.
You know, one of
the first things that goes
when you get older
is your memory,
so I don't know if you really --
I don't know if that's true.
I really don't know
if it's true.
It sounds good, though.
-It sounds good.
It's a good story.
Do you remember, one night,
we went out to another bar?
-Yeah, another night, right?
Yeah, another night.
I don't. I don't remember.
-You've got remember this one.
This was a good one.
This one, you might have
went home early,
but I don't remember.
But there's a guy -- I don't
even remember his name.
I won't say his name
if I do remember his name.
But he was a Yankee,
and he got so wasted.
I mean, he was drunk
and he gets up,
and we were at the same table.
And he gets up and he's like,
"I'm gonna go to the bathroom"
or something like that.
And he goes up to this door,
and we're all like,
"No, no, wait, dude.
John --" or whatever
his name was.
And he goes, "Whatever, man."
And he opened the door, and it
wasn't the door to the bathroom.
It was the emergency exit.
-And he fell out.
Yeah, and fell out.
That is a true story.
-He fell out.
-That is a true story.
-And I remember seeing his shoes
and the doors are closed,
and none of us
got up to help him.
-Just to clarify, he wasn't
with us before we went out.
He met us there.
-That is true.
Oh, yeah, that's true.
-He met us there.
-No, he did meet us there.
-He met us there, yes.
-But I didn't see the guy
ever again in my life.
I didn't know
what happened to him.
-I never saw him again either.
-Oh, my gosh.
We had some good times.
I want to talk about
the Turn 2 Foundation,
because, man, you do
so much good stuff for charity.
I think you've raised
over $34 million with Turn 2.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
Which is amazing, what you do.
-Thank you very much.
-These young people.
You're having the Derek Jeter
Celebrity Invitational
golf tournament in a few months.
You're obviously
the one running it.
And I just find
it very interesting --
you've never won
your own tournament.
[ Laughter ]
-Why is that funny?
-It's no big deal.
I just think it's funny,
because someone has to win
the tournament when you play.
-I think it's two things.
One, if you win
your own tournament,
people think it's rigged.
So, you want people to come back
and continue to spend money
and hope they have
a chance to win.
So you can't just go out
and win your own tournament.
And, two,
I'm not very good at golf.
I mean, I -- You can relate.
-What?
-You can relate.
-You know what's fun?
-We go way back.
There's no --
He'll agree to this.
-You know what's funny, though?
I mean, I don't even recall,
I mean, the past winners
of your tournament
and stuff like that, but...
-Like I said, it was rigged.
You won one year.
So we've got to have Jimmy back.
-How does it feel
to sit next to a champion?
[ Laughter ]
Did that drive you --
I remember you were so mad.
You were smiling
because you had to take
a photo with the winners.
And it's me,
and you're going like,
"I can't believe
I got to do this."
And I have the photo somewhere.
-That's a true story.
But, you know,
your handicaps play into golf,
so the worse you are,
it actually helps out your team.
-Yeah, it really did.
-Yeah.
Was that the time my mom called?
-Yeah, it was the time --
He overslept the next day.
He was missing his flight
to go home.
His mom actually was calling
all of our staff
trying to track down Jimmy.
That is a true story.
-There's other things
I want to talk to you about.
I want to talk to you about
your athletic wear.
This is Greatness Wins.
-Yes.
-And, dude,
congratulations on this.
This is cool that you get
to do stuff like this.
And, like, of course.
You're one of the
best athletes in the world.
You're the greatest athlete
I've ever seen play
in the history
of any sport ever.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, really?
-I'm honored to get to know you,
but just to watch --
You're unbelievable.
-Well, I appreciate it.
He made a -- You know, he made
a movie with the Boston Red Sox,
so now he tries
to make up for that.
-Thank you very much.
Thank you very much.
-He tries to make up for that.
-I deserve an Oscar for that.
-Yeah, you do.
Are you a Boston fan?
-Yeah.
I'm a Yankee fan,
but at the time,
I was an actor
and I was playing a role.
I mean, you know what
acting is, right?
You know...
-I remember meeting Spike Lee
my first year.
And I'm a big fan of Spike.
I'd never met him before.
He came to a game, and I said,
"Hey, Spike, man,
when are you going to let me
act in one of your movies?"
He says, "Hey, why don't you act
like being a short stop today."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal crash ]
Yeah.
-Come on. That's awesome.
Come on.
-It's a true story. It is true.
-On Monday, it was announced,
the cover athlete for
"MLB The Show 23."
It's someone
that you know very well.
-Yep.
-This is Miami Marlins
center fielder
Jazz Chisholm right there.
You know -- You're the one
that helped get Jazz
on the Marlins, is that correct?
-I did, yes. I did.
You know, the great thing about
Jazz is, he's from the Bahamas,
and baseball is
such an international sport.
You love to see this,
because, you know,
he's setting an example for
young men and women
growing up in the Bahamas,
knowing that
they have an opportunity
to make it to, you know,
the top of their profession.
So I couldn't be prouder of him.
-It's a big deal
to be on the cover.
-Oh, yeah. Yes.
-But there's also a collector's
edition of "MLB The Show"
that has someone
different on the cover.
And I have the
first copy of it right here.
That is Derek Jeter
right there on the cover.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, bud.
That's what I'm talking about.
Back on the cover of the game!
-Thank you.
Thank you, thank you. Thank you.
You know,
I've been contemplating
coming out of retirement
for a few years.
-We're waiting for
this moment right here.
Do you have an announcement?
-Yeah, I figured it's a lot
easier to do it in a video game
than it actually is to do
in real life.
-I mean, come on.
That's got to --
Do you remember playing yourself
for the first time
in a video game?
-I do. Yeah, I do.
And when you play
the first time,
first of all,
it's an awesome experience
playing as yourself,
'cause you grew up
and you're playing
as your favorite players,
but then, you know,
my mind just went to,
"How can I rig it so,
actually, that my performance
is better in the video game than
it actually is on the field?"
I didn't figure that out,
but that's my first thought.
-Yeah, you can't do --
Yeah, they actually --
I wanted to see what
I would look like if I was
in the video game, and our
friends at "MLB The Show"
mocked this up.
What do you think of this guy?
-Wow.
-Look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow. Well, I would --
-The guns are --
-Yeah, I would first -- Yeah.
That's what I'd point out.
The arms are not really
proportionate or, you know --
-It's fantastic.
That looks exactly like me.
-And I've never seen you look
serious, so this is another one.
So, have you played
baseball before?
-Yeah. I'm very athletic.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I'm athletic.
I've played baseball.
I've played golf.
-We're going to get you
some Greatness Wins gear.
There you go.
-Will you get me some?
-I will, I will so you can
look athletic and --
-Look athletic? I am athletic.
I've won golf tournaments.
It's very famous.
We've all seen Derek Jeter,
what a Derek Jeter
home run has looked like,
but there's something
we haven't seen.
Let's take a look at this.
-Now batting, number 24,
Jimmy Fallon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, buddy! Focus up.
Yes! Oh, my!
Look at that shot.
-If you are actually going --
If you're actually going to
make this realistic,
they should have you run around
the bases the other way.
I think that would work.
That would work for you.
-Congratulations
on everything --
the kids, the cover,
Turn 2, by the way.
Come back whenever you want.
Please, next week, come back.
Derek Jeter, everybody.
"MLB The Show's"
"Collector Edition"
is available starting
March 24th.
We'll be right back with
Rita Ora.